hello and welcome to this episode of
Google developers live I'm Sarah Maddox
from the Google Maps developer relations
team and I'm going to show you how to
use map padding with the Google Maps
Android API let's say you have an
application that has a map and you want
to add a sidebar to the map but you
don't want to hide the map UI controls
or the Google logo let's see what
happens if you add a sidebar without
adding map padding this little demo app
has a sidebar on the right and as you
can see the find my location control is
at the top right but it's obscured by
the sidebar and similarly the map zoom
controls are at the bottom right and
they're completely hidden so what I've
done with this application is add a
button called padded and if I touch the
padded button the application calls a
method which adds 30 pixels of padding
on the right-hand side of the map so you
can see that the UI controls are now
nicely displayed slightly to the left of
my sidebar the map still takes up the
entire view but the user controls and
the gestures behave as if they're only
using up the smaller visible portion of
the map so I'm going to tap the find my
location control and you can see that
the little blue location indicator is
nicely positioned in the center of the
map it's taken met padding into account
now if I touch the normal button which
removes map padding from my map and then
touch the find my location button again
you'll see that the location indicators
move slightly to the right and it seems
to be off-center and that's because it's
taking the whole map into account
instead of just the visible portion okay
I'm going to touch Sydney and position
the center of the map in Australia so
that there's a nice lot of blue see
around and that means that you can see
the Google logo at the bottom left of
the screen now it's worth noting that
your application needs to show the
Google logo if it hides the Google logo
then it's not in compliance with the
Terms of Service of the Google Maps API
s so if you need to add UI controls at
the bottom left of your map map padding
is a good way to make sure that the
Google logo appears ok let's take a look
at the code it's very simple use the
Google map set padding method to add
padding around the edges of the map the
method takes four parameters to
determine the padding on the left top
right and bottom edges and the parameter
names are easy to remember left top
right and bottom camera updates such as
resetting the map will automatically
take care of the padding so you don't
need to calculate the offset yourself
and you can dynamically change map
padding at any time the details are in
the documentation also take a look at
the Google Maps API demo app that
shipped with the Google Play services
here's a link to the documentation about
the demo app it has a more complex
example than the one I've shown you for
example it has allows you to add some
animation to slide your sidebar in and
out the padding demo is called visible
regions in the demo app menu thank you
and I hope you've enjoyed this video
from Google developers live